fallout 4 is first expansion hits next
month but we just got some more insight
into what the automaton DLC pack will
offer we already know that the DLC
revolves around the evil mechanist
releasing his robot forward into the
Commonwealth but thanks to a leaked
achievement list we can deduce just what
the vault dwellers will do about that
threat the list was originally pooled by
xbox achievements but now you can check
out the full list on Steam the new
achievements are listed below the main
game they're titled robot hunter the
most toys headhunting mechanical menace
and restoring order these may be quest
or character related but one thing is
for sure there's a good chunk of new
stuff to check out when utama Tron
releases and on that note at Omicron
hits ps4 xbox one and pc in march and
it'll cost you ten bucks of course you
can always grab the fallout 4 season
pass for thirty dollars just do it
before march first when the price jumps
to 50 for more info on fallout 4s other
DLC packs including wasteland workshop
and Farah Harbor you're already in the
right place
Oh